(audience applauding)
- We're very earth tonesy today.
- Earth tonesy, is that what you said?
- Yeah, it's like we called each other.
- Yep.
I brought you a gift.
- I love Smithworks, you know that.
But what's this?
- Well that is the Smithworks mascot.
- That is you.
- Which is me.
180 pounds ago.
- I'm gonna use it as a voodoo doll.
- A what?
- A voodoo doll (laughs).
- (laughs) And it's got
I don't know how I'm supposed
to talk about this now
'cause there's all kinds of legal issues
so I'm just gonna sit him down
(audience laughs)
- Oh yeah yeah I get it.
Let's toast though because tonight y'all
is The Voice finale on NBC.
(audience applauds)
So.
- See that right there?
What that means
It looks disgusting but it means pick me.
(audience laughs)
Okay, this deal.
- Everyone knows I'm gonna
win, I'm just kidding.
Here you go.
Okay I will say most
times drinking with you
it doesn't end well for me but it's fine.
- Ah I wish I could tell
some stories on your show.
- You can't. No.
- This show would be so
much better if I could tell
some of the crap that you've done.
- No they
- Yes.
- They, just dream, just
think about what could happen.
Cheers.
- Wait a minute what are we toasting to?
The finale?
- We're literally toasting the finale.
Hey congratulations.
- To Jake
- and Ricky.
Yeah. And Rose.
- I gotta say though
I'm amazed that Jake has made it that far
with the worst coach in
the history of the show.
- Oh my god, you are
- That's unbelievable.
- Yeah.
He made it all the way to the finale
'cause I'm horrible.
- Yep.
(audience applauds)
Pretty good. I love it.
- So speaking of drinking of so many jobs
like myself, and you have is
it 3 restaurants right now
and you're opening a fourth?
- There is, so there's
an Ole Red in Tishomingo.
- Mmhmm.
- (laughs)
- What are you laughing about?
- Well 'cause it's why is there one there?
Because that's kind of where I live.
- Yeah.
Well that's why.
- (laughs)
- And then there's one in Nashville.
Then there's one in Gatlinburg
and then we're about
to open one in Orlando.
And there's others in the works.
(audience applauds)
- That's a really smart place to open one.
Because of all the stuff to do there
that's really smart.
- There's way smarter people than me
that decide where those
things go, clearly.
- Clearly (laughs)
Did you choose Tishomingo?
- I can't believe you did a shot of vodka
I can already tell you're
starting to act weird.
(audience laughs)
I told 'em I said there's
no way she's gonna actually
do a shot of vodka.
- No, I do tequila. I did
tequila with Nick. I've done
- On the show?
- Yeah I've done rosé with
Chrissy O's John's I drink.
- A shot of rosé.
- No but I drink, I drink, yeah.
I drink on the, this show is fun.
(audience applauds)
- So petty about it.
- No I'm not.
But hey, in all seriousness
with God's Country
you won CMA single of the year right?
- Mmhmm.
- Congratulations.
- Thank you.
- That's really cool.
(audience applauds)
- ♪ God's Country ♪
- And he's also nominated
for a Grammy coming up, yes.
(audience applaud)
I mean this was, you've had like
I know like 50,000 number ones
but this was, was this your biggest one?
God's Country was that
the biggest out of all
- No you never know
until couple years later
when you get past it
and look back you know
but it's gotta be.
I mean that was a big record
you know. - It seems to be yeah
- And for me to get nominated for a Grammy
I mean they hate me at the
Grammys so for them to be like
Oh my god just nominate
him, just put him in there
it's fine, it's fine.
- No, I can't believe 'cause
you told me this one time
and I found this shocking
because you're so
like even outside people that
aren't into country music,
like everyone knows you.
And everyone knows your music
even if they don't listen
to country regularly
like you're just so massive,
you're like beyond country.
But anyway my favorite album of yours
I know this one's real popular but
my favorite's still your second one.
Let me show everyone why
this is my favorite one.
Yes.
(audience applauds)
I mean.
- Come on!
- I mean.
What it is.
Look at that stare.
Look at that stare and all that hair.
(audience laughs)
I do have a surprise for you though
and I was excited to be
able to do this for you
but, Elf will you come on out here?
(audience applauds)
This is awesome.
- Whoa, look at that.
- Because on behalf of Blake's label
Warner Music Nashville
I wanna present Blake
with this double platinum
plaque in honor of
God's Country, sold more
than two million copies y'all
that's amazing.
(audience applauds)
I talk about playlists a lot
because it's full of randomness.
I like his playlist
the first time we hung out I know
I've said this story before
but I was so shocked (laughs)
I was like is this Duran Duran?
Like you have the most random playlist so
you're totally country
obviously but you have like
a pretty broad
- Listen to everything.
- Yeah you have a really broad playlist so
to find out why Blake loves
some of those random songs
we came up with a little game
'cause I know he loves games.
Called, I just bring my friends here and
make them do stuff they don't wanna do.
It's called Celebrity Playlist Shuffle.
(audience applauds)
(dramatic jingle)
All right so here's how it works, okay.
I hit this button.
- Whoa, wait a minute
Is this the same piece of
crap button that you had
- Do you wanna offer some
money, you wanna be a sponsor
for this season?
- No I'm just saying.
- It's the first season.
- Is this on, we're on television, right
this is a big show, didn't you get renewed
for another season?
- We did but we don't have the money yet.
- You get a damn button.
(audience applauds)
- We don't have the money yet.
- Wait a minute
where's the Elf? I brought you something.
- You brought me a gift?
- That's kind, okay what is it?
- Yes.
Elf, can you please bring
that is embarrassing.
- (laughs)
- How come the Elf don't
come when I say it.
Oh here he is.
(audience applauds)
- Oh my god it has drink.
- This is the new and
improved Kelly Clarkson
stupid game podium.
- Stupid game. Wait does it light up
Oh!
- See whatever game that
you make your friends play.
- It lights up.
- As long as you have to be
uncomfortable on this show
playing your weird games.
- Yeah.
- Now you actually have like
a nice podium that's got
look here, rear view
mirrors in case somebody
- Someone's coming at me.
- Like you do that deal where you know
like a soldier is gonna
surprise a family member.
But it doesn't work because
'cause the kid's like
oh my god there's Dad!
- (laughs)
(audience laughs)
- It's not gonna work now.
- It's not gonna work, it's ruined.
- Got the cup holders.
- I like that.
It's kinda like beer pong
but it's button pong.
- And my favorite
because every time you use
this I want people to know
(audience applauds)
that Blake is awesome.
- I'm actually gonna keep that on here.
- Blake is awesome, okay?
- That's amazing.
Okay, so wait. Is he on this side?
Okay, okay you go on this side.
- Hey thank you for my gift.
- You're welcome I built it myself.
- You think I'm joking
but I'm gonna keep that
- Oh you're keeping that on there.
- For like every episode.
Are you tossing it? Okay.
All right here's how it works people
thank you for this beautiful
display of buttoness.
- You're welcome I built it.
- You're amazing, awh.
Liar.
(audience laughs)
I hit this button, so if I hit this button
our super computer shuffles
through Blake's playlist
lands on a song and Blake tell us
what that songs means to him.
- How do you know if you win or anything?
Like what?
- No it's more like a
game of like figuring out
like getting inside why you have this song
on your playlist because most people
wouldn't expect some of the songs
- You see why your games are awful?
You can't even win.
- It's the first season!
No you did play a game on the
show and I did win (laughs)
All right, here we go, we're gonna go.
(tense rumbling)
There we go.
(bell ding)
Okay, oh.
Escape (The Piña Colada Song)
- Wait a minute, is that
your song or my song?
- That's yours.
- That's my, 'cause I
have that on my playlist.
- I know this is your playlist.
- Oh okay.
- (laughs)
- This is a
(audience laugh)
what did I win?
- You win
- What the hell do I win here?
(audience laugh)
- Why do you have that
song in your playlist?
- I have that on my lake playlist
'cause when we go out to the lake
there's a bunch of weird, you know
random songs like that on there
- Do you have I'm on a Boat?
- No.
- Do you know that song?
- Brandon loves that song.
- Brandon and I play
that song I'm on a Boat.
- When you sing it one time
you're like okay I got it
it was funny but I can't
imagine listening to that
over and over again.
- No after drinking it's still funny.
- Really?
- Yeah. I promise.
(bell ding)
We're gonna go again.
- Wait a minute
(tense music)
(bell ding)
Is this just my songs?
- My Life Billy Joel
yes you have to tell
me, it's your playlist.
- I thought we were going,
doing it back and forth.
- Have you been drinking? No.
- Yes. Yes I have.
- No, it's your playlist.
- Oh okay I thought we were
doing it back and forth.
- No.
- I have that on there
because it reminds me
when I was a kid there
was a television show
called Bosom Buddies.
- I loved Bosom Buddies.
- That was the theme song
to, which I'm sure it was
probably a hit song besides that.
- Let's do the next one.
(tense music)
(bell ding)
East Bound and Down
oh that used to be a show, Jerry Reed
did you ever see Eastbound
& Down that TV show
it was funny.
- No.
Jerry Reed that's from
Smokey and the Bandit
'member the movie Smokey and the
- Oh yeah Sally Field.
- Yeah.
- I loved him with the mustache.
- Yes.
- No, no. I'm thinking of Tom Selleck
I liked him too though
- That wasn't Tom Selleck
it was Burt Reynolds.
- No I'm thinking, I
know it's Burt Reynolds
but I was thinking of Tom Selleck.
- How does anybody get
a word in on your show?
How does anybody get a word in
you have a talk show that you talk on.
(audience laughs)
- Exactly.
So why do you like that song?
- Oh it's just one of
my all time favorites.
It reminds me of that movie,
Smokey and the Bandit, love that movie.
Had a cool Trans Am on
there, Burt Reynolds.
Burt Reynolds, not Tom Selleck.
- No I know I was thinking
and then I thought
oh it's Tom Selleck yeah.
- That's what I was thinking in my head.
- Who's Tom, no Tom
Selleck's not on there.
- I just mean they all had
mustaches, those mustaches.
- Okay, yes.
- We have to take a break our first
- Thank god.
(audience laughs)
Please, if there's any
advertisers left for the show
please run your commercial for Kelly.